every path and every mistake and up and
down and in between in my entire life I
feel like it's already been you know
planned out for me
Naya Rivera is missing after taking a
boat ride with her four-year-old son
Josie on Wednesday you know I'm a mom
now and I you know what I love more than
acting is being Josie's mom so I want to
be here for him and I don't want to miss
anything the Ventura County Sheriff's
Department told NBC LA that the former
glee actress and her son rented a boat
around 1:00 p.m. on Lake Peru in the Los
Padres National Forest in Ventura County
California approximately three hours
later another boater discovered Josie
whom she shares with her ex-husband
Ryan Dorsey in the boat by himself
officials told NBC LA that Nyhus son was
wearing a life vest while she was not
the search immediately kicked off with
the use of helicopters divers and drones
but the 33 year olds has not been found
authorities reportedly presume Naya to
be dead
late Wednesday evening the Sheriff's
Department announced that they were
suspending the search until the morning
and on Thursday authorities posted on
Twitter that they were again out looking
for Naya with the help of dive teams
adding that the lake will be closed to
the public
shortly after news of nya's
disappearance broke her former Glee
co-star Harry Shum Jr tweeted that he
was praying another Glee alum Heather
Morris posted to her insta story writing
we need all the prayers we can get to
bring our Anaya back home to us we need
your love and light nigh as ex-fiancee
Big Sean didn't post a message of his
own but did show that her safety was on
his mind
liking several tweets about the search
for the star Demi Lovato also took to
Instagram asking her fans to please pray
for Naya Rivera to be found safe and
sound